今僕がこの黒板で書いたリストから見ると
全部七つ出てこなくちゃいけないでしょうし
ですからまた二つ残ってるんだから
その場合も同じ禅定 禅定の心が生まれて消えると
またいろいろ差があるんです
差があるんだけど 大体順番はそういう順番なんです
で それだけでは説明足らないと思いますけどね
いろいろ説明します で
人が禅定を作る前に もう何年間も瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
瞑想して特別な経験を得られるんです
例えば 目で見たものを目が閉じても見えるということは
ものすごい違う経験なんです
で だいたいこれ一般の社会にいて瞑想できるわけでもないんです
社会から確実に離れなさいと言っているんです
例えば青い色を瞑想した人がいたならば
それで目を閉じても その人は自分の瞑想しているものを見えちゃうんですね
すると そればっかりやっちゃうと心がそうなるんです
そこでその人は瞑想をやめてご飯を食べようとしたっても
ご飯は全部青い色で見えるんです
人を見ても全然この服の色とかも見えない
全部同じ色で一色です
なぜならば 心はまたものすごい違うことを慣れてるんだから
もう気にならないというかね
外の情報には ですから
そういう人はすごく気をつけて
人と喋らないでいた方がいいんです
間違ってでも なんで今日ご飯は青いですか？と言っちゃったら混乱させちゃうんですね
そこの人々が なんで青いわけないで
それは白いですよと あんた瞑想しすぎて頭おかしいですよとか何とか言うかもしれません
あるいはそれ本人が理解して
その青いシャツを着ている方なんですけど
実はその人は青いシャツじゃなくて黄色いシャツ着ているかもしれませんし
ですから喋らない方がいいんです
判断しない方がいいんです
見るものについてすごく気をつけなくちゃいかない
自分の瞑想体験はもっと大事なんです
そういうことで あまり社会に入らなくていなくちゃいけないんですね
その瞑想する場合は で
そういう風に長い間修行するんです
この修行する状態 例えば目で目を閉じても瞑想対象見える状態がパリカンマの状態なんですね working
準備状態 下 なんて言いますか
下ごしらえの状態なんです
まだ料理してないんです
でも全部準備は全部している状態
そこにはまあこの瞑想するたびに意識の中でパリカンマ
心だけジャワ通して生まれて生まれて生まれていっちゃうんです
でも禅定は出てこない
そこで同じ 例えば青い色だけ見て見ている人が瞑想すると
なんとなく心落ち着いて
妄想が消えちゃって 青いだけ見ているような感じにもなります
その時はウペチャーラ状態なんですね
なんかサマーディにちょっと似たような状態になっちゃうんですね
でもまだサマーディじゃない
なぜならば 強引に瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
サマーディの味を味わってないんです
ですから 人がもう 1週間
2週間  1ヶ月とか何年間でも
このジャワの即行心が生まれるんだけど
その即行心がパリカルマで終わるか
パリカルマとウペチャーラで終わるかとかわからないんです
そのように瞑想して瞑想して
ある日やっとアヌノーマという心まで生まれるんですね
即行心 アヌノーマっていうのはサマーディ状態にものすごく似ている状態の心が生まれる
それでもサマーディが生まれない場合あるんです
自分の心の状態で見れば
これはサマーディ状態ではないかと
どう見たってサマーディ状態なんですけど
でも瞑想しなきゃその状態は保てないんですね
ですから それにも時間がかかる可能性はあるんですね
そこで修行中で もう瞑想するとジャガナという七つ生まれるんだけど
それはパリカルマ七つか
パリカルマ半分とウペチャーラ半分か
いろいろからくりあって生まれて生まれてきて
たまにたまにアヌノーマまでいっちゃうとかね
あるいはある時もう一番目のジャガナ・パリカルマで
次にアヌノーマばっかり生まれてきて
それで次にウブンシンに落ちると
七つ終わったらウブンシンに行っちゃうんですね
そういう風に修行して修行して
じゃあ最後の瞬間に出会ったと
サマーディ 本物のサマーディが生まれる瞬間に出会っても
出会った時このリストになるんです
一番目の即行心はパリカルマ
準備する 二番目はもうほとんど似ている状態
もうもう料理できる状態になったと
で もうほとんど似ている
サマーディに似ている状態になると
同じゴートラブっていうのは日本語で何と言いますかね
首証 首証という心ですね
で 首証という心が生まれちゃうんですね
この首証という心が生まれたら
次の心は確実に禅定の心
この二つはもう離れません
いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
禅定の前の心に首証心と言うんです
まあそれだけのこと ですから首証心生まれたら確実にサマーディは何ですかではなくて
もう禅定が生まれる心に
の前の心に首証心という
次の問題はなぜ首証心と言うんですかと
そこでゴートラという言葉があるんですね
その言葉を分析してみましょう
ゴートラ それからブーですね
そのゴートラとブーという言葉
ゴートラというのはファミリーですよ
家という意味なんですね
あの内という意味ではなくて
この何々家とか田中家とかね
そういう風に言う あのファミリーのこと
ブーっていうのはなりましたということなんですね
いわゆる生まれたっていう同じ意味でもいいんです
これどんなファミリーかというと
やっぱり次元を超えた世界の人々のファミリーに入ったということ
いわゆるこの禅定の心を作る前の心で
すべての資格をそろっ禅定を作る資格をそろって
そろったならば 次に瞬間に自動的にサマーディ禅定の心が生まれるんです
で 一般的な言葉をなぜ使っているかというと
これはサマーディ瞑想にもヴィパッサナー瞑想にも同じ言葉で説明しようとアビダンマで思っているんです
で ゴートラブ心も欲界心の善心の即行心なんです
善心八種類ありますし
ソウマナッサーガタン
ニャーナサントーイッタン
アサンカーリカン ササンカーリカン
トガナ ソウマナッサーガタン
ニャーナイットイッタン
アサンカーリカン ササンカーリカン
ウペッカーサガタン ニャーナサントーイッタン
ウペッカーサガタン ニャーナイットイッタン
アサンカーリカン ササンカーリカンという八つ
八種類あります その八種類の一つで即行心としてずっと生まれるんだけど
そこでその心が波が変わって
このステップで禅定の心が生まれる
ですからゴートラブまでは欲界
ジャーナからは色界 一番目のジャーナで禅定だったら色界
二番目の まあ色界では五つありますね
禅定が  第一 第二 第四 第五禅定ありますから
そこはまあ色界 もしその人がずっと瞑想して色界終わった人だったら
こちらは無色界 でもこちらは欲界
そこで次元が変わるんですね
だからゴートラブという言葉だから使っているんです
次元が変わる瞬間 だから日本語で種姓と言ってますけど
なんで種というか ちょっとその漢字が入ったかわかりませんだけど
パーリ語のゴートラっていうのはグループ
ファミリーという意味なんです
そのファミリーに生まれようとする
生まれたらそのファミリーの人
赤ん坊がもう生まれようとしているんです
生まれたらその家の人なんです
そこでこのリストでは
このジャーナ また二つ
即行心の穴が二つありますね
その穴二つにまた同じ禅定
禅定生まれて 次にウブンシンになっちゃうんです
もしその瞑想した人が
の心がパリカンマ 一番目の心が二回生まれたならば
ここで一つ禅心が一つ抜けちゃうんです
ウパチャーラもアヌローマも二回ずつ生まれる可能性あります
でもパリカンマ二回生まれて
ウパチャーラも二回生まれちゃったら
まあ一応どうなるんです
その場合は ジャーナに場所がなくなっちゃうんですね
ジャーナが生まれません
禅心が生まれなくなる
禅定の心が生まれなくなっちゃうんです
だからこちらの数はもう一応決まっておかないとダメなんです
で ここパリカンマでこちらもパリカンマだったら
次に三番目ウパチャーラ
四番目アヌローマ 五番目ゴートラブ
じゃあそれで ここウパチャーラ
こちらアヌローマ こちらゴートラブーダッカ
こちらジャーナ生まれるんですね
二つ分けがあるんですね
ですからジャーナ二つ生まれるんです
もしパリカンマも二つになって
これも二つになっちゃったら
もう一つしか残ってない
それでも禅定が生まれる可能性はありますけど
ですから瞑想してもしても禅定の心が生まれないんです
そこでやってやってやってやって
ある一定数全部条件が揃ったら
このセットで禅定の心が生まれる
そこで性格分析がありますから
この智慧が早く現れる人
ゆっくり現れる人とかありまして
早く現れる人にとっては
これはこれを一番早く現れる人のリストなんです
これは一つ一つ一つでさっさっさと禅定が生まれるんです
智慧がゆっくり現れる人にとっては
パリカンマは伸びちゃうし
アヌローマも伸びる可能性あるし
伸びたらやっと一つの心で禅定が生まれてウブンシンになってしまっちゃうんです
ですからサマーディもそれほど強く感じないんですね
ほんの瞬間の出来事なんです
本人は長い時間通して感じるかもしれない
時間関係消えちゃいますから
そこら辺ではない で ほんの瞬間の出来事なんですけど
その出来事でもう心の次元が変わってしまう
で このアノーローマっていう言葉とゴートラブーっていうことはもうちょっと説明しなくちゃいけないんですけど
これどういう言葉かというと
このテキストではこの街に例えているんですね
祭りに例えているんです
で 我々は村では自分の家にいるんだと
で 街で祭りやってるんだ
それで祭りに参加したいんです
そこでずっと歩いていく状態は修行している
瞑想している状態で そこで街に近寄ってくると
祭りの音なんかは聞こえてくるんですね
それはパリカンマ状態なんですね
いわゆるウパチャーラ状態なんです
何か音が聞こえて 太鼓の音が聞こえてくるとかね
音楽が聞こえてくるとかね
さらに近寄っちゃうと
もう祭りの場所にほとんどもう側に来たんだと
側に来たらもうほとんどもう見えたり聞こえたりするんです
そこで祭りしている玄関に入ったと
玄関に入ったらもう中に入ったことと同じなんです
それはゴートラブーと言うんですね
祭り場所の玄関に入って
もし入場料金払わなくちゃいけないんだったら
それを払ってもうチケットを手に入ったと
それだったら別に誰も問題ないで
そのまま入っちゃえばいいんです
ですから ゴートラブーっていうのはなんか入場券を取って
玄関で入場券を取ったぐらいのことなんです
ここからは戻れませんね
入場券を取って もうそこ一歩先祭りの場所だから
じゃあもう帰ろうとはありえないんですね
ここら辺で帰ることはありますよ
側まで行ったんだけど
まだまだお金足らなかったと
という場合だったら入れないんですね
じゃあ今度にしましょうとしなくちゃいけない
ですから 瞑想中でも準備足らない場合は
このパリカンマ ウパチャーラだけ生まれて
もう修行してそれで終わってサマーディが生まれない
ですから 何回何回も繰り返し繰り返し修行して修行して
全部心の準備を整えたところで
ゴートラブーの心が生まれる
ゴートラブーの心が生まれたら
必ずその次に禅定の心が生まれる
それは禅定が生まれるシステムです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でも覚る時も同じシステムで
パリカンマ ウパチャーラ
アノーローマ ゴートラブーとマッガとファラ
ちょっと言葉変わるだけ
マッガっていうのは道とファラは果です
で あれ書いてないんですかね
出世検身の方書いてないか
うん うん まあ説明これはたくさんもうたくさんありますけども
じゃああのヴィパッサナーの場合はどうなるかというと
あの こういう風になるんです
まずこの禅定の場合はこの取捨取捨心がありますね
ゴートラブ ゴートラブではもう入場券買ったことだから
で ここらここら辺でこのパンチャ・ニワラナ
五蓋がもう活動しなくなっちゃうんです
その心に これからは 抑えちゃうんですね
抑えた瞬間で禅定が生まれる
そこでヴィパッサナー瞑想すると禅定は生まれません
その代わりに まあ預流果
一来果 不還果 阿羅漢果という四つの悟りの段階が生まれるんですね
で 普通の人がヴィパッサナー瞑想して悟ろうとすると
一番最初に現れるのは預流果の道なんですね
ですから このゴートラブまで行くんです
ゴートラブまで行ったら
預流道心という心が生まれるんです
預流果ではなく預流道
マグダですね マグダで買えばどんなマグダでもいいんですから
一番最初だったらどうせ預流道心なんです
ゴートラブではどうなるかというと
やっぱり煩悩をまた抑えちゃう
抑えちゃうんだけど この特別な道心
預流道心という心が生まれる
この預流道心の特色は煩悩は遮断するんです
もう完全に消えちゃうんです
これ煩悩完全に消える心に道心というんです
遮断する心 もう二度と現れない
ここら辺に今押さえてますけど
預流果になる人が煩悩三つですね
サッチャーディティ ウシンケン
ギト カイゴンシュッというなんか三つあります
煩悩が サッチャーディティ
ビチキッチャー シーラッペタバラマー
ウシンケンというのは実体があるんだという誤解ですね
ビチキッチャーっていうのは今まであった疑いですよ
ものご 頭にあった混乱状態
それもしっかり無常見ているんだから
もう消えてるんですね
あのカイゴンシュッっていうのはいろんなこの病なんでね
修行に対する執着なんですね
なんとかしなきゃ それ何の意味もないんです
修行したって ヴィパッサナーしなくても
無常見なきゃ意味がないんです
でも人間っていうのはすごいいろんな修行にすごい執着を持ってるんです
修行に執着持っていたっても
単なる まあ何て言いますか
自分たった一つの娯楽みたいなもんなんですよ
他の人はもう酒飲んでふざけて遊んでると
もう一人の人がご飯も食べずに寝ずに修行して
それで解脱を考えているんだと
そういうやりたくはなるんだ
あれは欲だけなんです
やっぱりとにかく智慧をもって無常を見たいんだという気持ちだけヴィパッサナーなんですね
ですから この預流果になると
その三つの煩悩が完全に消えちゃう
この煩悩が完全に消える心に道心というんです
道は道 マグダは道だから
心が心 そういうことで
一人の人に道心というのは一回しか一生もう生まれない
輪廻の中でずっともう無始なる輪廻の中で生まれてきて
生まれてきて これから生まれ変わっていくかもしれませんだけど
その一人の生命に一回っきり道心が生まれる
二度と生まれません 生まれるのは不可能です
もう殺したものはもう一度殺してやりますということはできませんでしょう
ですから煩悩はもう殺してしまえば
その殺す心に 煩悩を殺す心に道心と呼ぶんです
ですから 一人の人による道心は一回
それから一来道心は一回と
普賢道心一回と 阿羅漢道心は一回しか生まれません
もう煩悩消えたということになるんです
そこもどういうことかというと
この智慧ということは光に例えてみると
強烈な光を与えてもらって物は見たんだと
見たら その人はもう知ってるんだから
何があるんですかと もう二度と騙されることはないんです
だから無知を見るんですね
無知を見たら なんとなく無常に納得しちゃう
それで有身見も解怨しょうも疑も消えちゃう
それからもうすごい心がしっかりしているんです
ですから このマッガチッタ
道心の前にまた守正心があるんですね
ゴートラブチッタがあるんです
だからゴートラブチッタはいつでも欲界なんです
欲界の心 欲界の心はここで終わっちゃう
ここで出世間心 もう輪廻を飛び出したと
色界もなし 無色界もなし
出世間心が生まれる マッガチッタの次に必ずも生まれるのはパラチッタなんです
パラチッタ パラは果と
結果の果と書くんですね
道と果と このミャンマーのテキストをよく読むと
皆様よく出会う言葉なのは道果ああだこうだとかね
急に道果涅槃と書いたって誰もわかりませんだけど
このことを言ってるんです
煩悩消えた 道心で 次の瞬間で涅槃を体験するんです
消えた瞬間 これこれの結果が
この人の場合はもう一つ残ってるんだから
それもパラチッタになっちゃうんです
それは出世間の過程なんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想して悟る時の
実はそういう風に悟りが生まれるんです
それもほんのわずかな瞬間なんです
大体そこら辺でいくらかは全部終わりましたけど
これから一般常識的な用語の説明なんですけど
このサマーディ禅定というものが一般の言葉で二つに分けてるんです
ウパチャーラ・サマーディ
アッパナー・サマーディ
それにアッパナー・サマーディ
まあ今から今使ってる
そういうこの今このいろんな言葉使ってるんで
そういうのはもうパーリ語でも一般パーリではないんです
全部もうもう特別な言葉なんです
ですから 辞書を引いても言語学的に分析しても
何の意味かわからない
で わざとこのそういう言葉使ってるんです
ウパチャーラっていうことぐらいは辞書にあるんで
ウパチャーラっていうのは寝ていると
ウパっていうのはそこら辺でまあまあうろうろという意味で
チャーラっていうのは歩いていると
そこら辺をうろうろ周り
もう回ってるんだと 中に入ったわけじゃないっていうことで
ウパチャーラ・サマーディっていうのはサマーディにほぼ近い状態
でもサマーディではありません
ですから ウパチャーラ・サマーディはいつでも欲界の心がすごい育てられた状態なんです
普通の心なんですけど
ものすごく育てられて
もうサマーディ状態のような落ち着いてる心を持ってると
それをウパチャーラ・サマーディと言うんです
でもそれは欲界心だと
アッパナー・サマーディっていうのは本物のサマーディを得た心
ウパチャーラ・サマーディは日本語で近行定ですね
近っていうのはまあ近く
行っていうのは歩くことで
定ってサマーディですね
サマーディの辺で歩いてる状態で
アッパナーは安止定と書いてあるんですね
もうサマーディに入って安定してそこに止まってる状態で
もうサマーディに入った状態
ですから 人間にはこの近行定っていうのは作られます
修行すると で そこでほとんどみんな納得して止まっちゃうんですね
もう心はもう清らかになって
なかなか怒りません なかなか欲が生まれませんと
いろんなことを目立っても落ち着いてるんだとかね
普通瞑想してそれで安心しちゃうんですよ
でも本当に本物のサマーディが
その体験なければ安心できないんです
まだ心は堕落する可能性あるんです
ですから このすごい厳密にサマーディを二種類に分けて
近行定と安止定と二種類に分けておくんです
だからほとんどの世の中の人々がこの近行定でもう納得して
あ これでいいと 先を見えないんですね
ですから サマーディという
特別に心の次元破って
欲次元破って上に飛んだという経験なければ
ただ納得だけではいけません
破った層と心に何か切れちゃうんですよ
認識のパターンで だからその何か切れた状態
何か破った状態 また戻れない状態は体験しなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 欲のない清らかな心で人はもう結構長い時間もいることはあるし
特にこの修行なんかやってると瞑想なんかやってると
もう清らかな心でずっといられることはできます
が なんか破った状態はないと思いますね
何か何かを枠 膜を破ってもう飛び出した状態が出てこない
そこを出てくるまでやらなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 最初からもうサマーディを二つに分けて教えているんです
それは修行者のために
それでこのリストを見ると
この心の流れのリストを見ると
このパリカンナ ウパチャーラ
アヌローマ ゴートラブまでは近行定
そこから禅定か道心か何とか生まれるでしょ
それには暗思定と言うんです
ゴートラブまでは近行定
ですから近行定にはたくさん心入りますけどね
このリストはウパチャーサもありで
こちらマッジャでもいいし
ジャーナでもいいんでしたらね
前書いたのはジャーナでしたからね
で ここからはこれですね
アッパナーサ そこからもうちょっと
ただランナについて それいうのうるさいんですね
このカショイについて
このテキストは もう一回すっ
あの
この百九ページにあの「タッタ ソーマナッササガタ ジャヴァナアンタラーナン アッパナーピ ソーマナッ
ササガタワ パーティカンキ タッバ」という行があります
で 「喜・苦・欲界即行心の直行に安心も喜・苦のみが期待されるべきである」と
ということで まあ私はあんまりそこはいいじゃないかなと思いますけど
で この禅定の場合は五つの禅定があるんです
色界では で 大体一番目
二番目 三番目 四番目までは喜・苦なんですね
喜びがあるんです 五番目の禅定は捨・苦なんです
第五禅定が で 喜も楽もないんです
ですから その禅定によって
例えば第一禅定を作る場合は
またこの心の流れを見ると
人が第一禅定を初めて作ろうとすると
第一禅定には必ずしも喜びがあるんです
喜悦感があるんです だから喜・無楽もあるんです
喜・無楽もあるんだから
このパリカンマ ウパチャーラ
アヌローマ ゴートブーという働きしてくれる欲界の善心がありますね
この欲界の善心では あの喜・苦の善心でやってくれるんだと
いわゆる禅定を作る前にも喜びの心があるんです
まあそんな難しいことじゃないんです
あの瞑想するとどんどん喜びが生まれてくるんです
で 疲れません 疲れるのは眼耳鼻舌身に頼っていると
どんどん眼耳鼻舌身に未練が消えて消えて
心が落ち着いてくると
体もものすごく楽になるんです
まあたまに体もものすごく軽く感じるんです
なんか綿のような 空気のような
体には何も物質ないんじゃないかなと
もし自分の体重を感じなくなっちゃったら
体はなんか浮いてる綿のように感じたったら
それほど喜びじゃないでしょ
人間には 今は体があるんだから痛くてしょうがない
立っていると疲れるわ
すごい体重だから 座っていると疲れるわ
歩くとか疲れるわ なぜならば重い荷物を運ばなきゃいけないんですね
もし心が落ち着いてきたところで
体の体重は感じなくなっちゃった
その人は歩いたっても疲れません
座っていても疲れません
そういうふうなこの瞑想では現れる現象たくさんあるんです
ですから 喜というのは
喜びっていうのは もう最初から禅定に入る前から生まれるんです
心が落ち着いてくると
もう喜びで ものすごく喜び感じちゃうんですね
で 喜びって言ったって
その喜びの質が違いますけど
もうただ何もなく なんとなく喜びがある
で 体はすごい軽い 心には何も希望ない
あれやらなくちゃ これやらなくちゃという
もう何もない その状態が喜びの状態なんです
なんかやらぬばという気持ちがあると
心は喜びにはないんです
で 瞑想すると もうただ瞑想するだけで
別に何か希望があるわけじゃないし
で 瞑想は気に入ってるし
体もすごい調子がいいし
そういう状態が出てくる
で そういうふうに瞑想しているんだから
その人の心にはどうせ
あの欲界の八善心が生まれる場合は
あの喜・苦の智恵相応の善心が生まれるんです
そこで第一禅定を作っちゃうと
それもまあ喜・苦なんです
だから第一 第二 第三 第四まで喜・苦だから
その時の前の即行心は全部喜・苦ですよと
ということを言ってるんです
言い方はちょっと問題ですけど
なぜならば第五禅定は捨・苦なんです
え？ [?] なになに？ 捨・苦の即行心の時は安心だけしか[?]
ならないよ そうならない
[?] だからもう決まってるんだから
第一禅定は喜・苦か捨・苦かとかね
第二禅定はもう決まってるんだから
例えば第二禅定の安心になったら同じ心でしょうに
決まってるんです なんかまあ私が間違ってるかどうかわかりませんだけど
まあほぼ私が間違う可能性は多いんだけど
で 私が言ってるのは 例えば第四禅定も終わったと
第四禅定も終わった人がもう喜びにも興味がない
喜びも捨てる 捨てて捨の状態になる
喜びもあまり激しいんだから
まあ結構ですと すごい激しい状態なのよ
喜びの状態 それは結構ですと
さらに落ち着きたいという第五禅定作ろうとする
その時の即行心はどうせもう捨・苦なんです
でも第一禅定の場合は捨・苦は生まれないとは思い-